new piece in the new york daily news
chastising republicans for expressing
well skepticism or saying outright
that they don't want the covert vaccine
they don't want the shot
look i'm going to get the shot i've said
it publicly which i don't have to do but
i want to
just share with my audience as much as i
feel like but when it's my turn in line
and i get the call
i talk to my doctor i choose to share
this and that's my decision
ironically i have friends half of them
agree half of them
do not agree at all and they will decide
for themselves in consultation with
their doctors not to get it
and president trump last night urged his
fellow americans to get the vaccine on
marie's show maria bartoromo that is
but the bottom line is that it isn't
really anyone's business
is it who gets the shot who doesn't get
the shot
i thought we have choice in this country
i thought
the choice to assess risk to do what's
best for ourselves and our families in
consultation with our doctors
and also what about medical privacy
never mind about choice because
i thought liberals were supposed to be
the leaders on pro-choice
not on the second amendment and recently
not even on the first amendment and
pretty much everything else
people every individual everybody out
there
you need to make your own decision make
you be free to make your own decision
and also
you're free to not share that decision
to maintain medical privacy between you
and your doctor
and as we've seen time and time again
those that shout the loudest
to force those of us to comply with
lockdowns mask mandates everything else
they also seem to often be the first to
break those rules all right here with
reaction south carolina senator lindsey
graham
senator you choose why are we even
asking senators this question
right
senator can you hear me there sean i
think you lost me i hear you
can you say worst words in the english
language i got to hear me now
can you hear me no okay i hear you now
okay
senators shouldn't have to disclose one
way they should be able to say
that's a decision between me and my
doctor end of the questioning
yeah yeah i consider my job a bit
different i'm a senator from south
carolina i'm urging you to get the
vaccination
i think it will help stop the spread of
the disease i think it's safe like
president trump
but i would never mandate you get the
vaccination it is your choice but i've
chosen as a
you know a leader in my state to lead by
example president trump did i tell you
this if you're a golfer he's 20 yards
longer so something worked for him
but i talked to him today about the vac
vaccine and he would urge everybody to
get the vaccine
but no mandates no man i agree and and
by the way medical privacies
stop asking people they want to
volunteer it now
yeah we have been told by joe manchin
he seems to be wobbly senator on the
issue of ending the legislative
filibuster
and now he seems to be coordinating with
joe biden because he said
yeah but i want to make the filibuster
tougher joe biden last night finally
answered that question and said pretty
much what mansion was suggesting
so hr1 ending the legislative filibuster
court packing dc puerto rico statehood
the biggest power grab in history sir
well it would be it would be
transformational to the country in a
really bad way it would destroy the
senate as we know it
anything big like this you should be
able to get a few votes from the other
side right
if you want to federalize the elections
and do away with redistricting by the
states and
turn it over to some commission that
will fundamentally change how you vote
if you only go to ballot harvesting
nationally and take authority away from
the states
should that be at least somewhat
bipartisan so i'm confident
i talked to joe manchin today that he's
not going to vote to abolish the
filibuster
but let me say this if they pick up one
more seat
in 2022 if they get 51 or 52 democratic
senators
they're going to abolish the filibuster
and transform america
i talked to president trump a lot today
he's focused like a laser on making sure
republicans
regain the senate and the house to stop
the most radical agenda in american
history
to the audience out there if you're
worried about everything sean talks
about
coming true make sure you vote
republican in 2022.
you said you talked to joe manchin this
is an important question because he said
i want to make it harder
joe biden last night said he wants to
bring back oh if you want a filibuster
you have to
actually have to get up and keep talking
and you don't get to get a bathroom
break
okay that would be bringing it back but
then there would be an end to the
filibuster
then mitch mcconnell waited and said
it's going to be like a 100 car pile up
because
you're going to have to have a quorum or
or
unanimous consent to even turn the
lights on at noon
which i kind of like for mitch mcconnell
surprised me
well no mitch is right a 50-50 senate
you can't do anything without unanimous
consent that matters
and to have a quorum you got to have 51
people present and the vice president
doesn't count so if they did this we
could really shut down the entire
senate because we just won't show up and
here's
what bide needs to understand if you go
to the talking filibuster
we will take the floor to stop hr1 i
would talk to i fell over
to make sure that we don't go to ballot
harvesting and voting by mail without
voter id
i would talk to i fell over to make sure
that the equality act doesn't become law
destroying the difference between a man
and woman and our law so
you can't do anything else do you
believe
so there's no way they're going to get
away with ending the legislative
filibuster
not with the 50 50 senate but i'm here
to tell you
that if we do not pick up one more seat
in 2022 or at least regained the house
if they had 52 democrats they would deal
joe manchin out
and they would change the rules of the
senate you know when we're in charge
they write me letters wanting me to say
i won't change the filibuster
to protect the senate now they're in
charge are willing to throw everything
over
and at the end of the day 2022 is the
the best hope for us to stop this crazy
stuff
i totally agree and by the way you were
way ahead of the curve
conversations i had with you even even
right after the election about the
border becoming now the big issue it is
you're dead on worst is yet to come
worse
worst is yet to come